i want to start off by saying essential
items aside
you should be wearing a mask you should
be sanitizing your hands
and if you don't do that right here i
got something for you
it's a clown's license
[Music]
what's up gq i'm black bear and these
are my essential items
[Music]
my first item is your average heating
pad it plugs right into the wall
i have chronic pancreatitis which means
my pancreas really sucks really bad and
hurts very bad all the time when i eat
food and stuff like that
so when i'm laying down watching movies
or even on the tour bus i plug this
sucker in
it gets real hot and it makes me feel
warm and it's like my own little
uh cuddly
teddy bear dunhill cologne
i don't know what the smell is but you
can identify it by the bottle
if you search dunhill it'll come up
there's a gold one the silver one is the
best it's unisex
smells fruity it smells sexy i wear it
all the time
this dunhill smells like what i think
fergie's butt crack smells like it's
like gorgeous it's like
god lit a match and mixed it with g-eazy
santel can't
candle and and then made a song
featuring black bear
[Music]
other than my apple watch i'm not like a
rolly guy
i'm not like a iced out i'm i might be
one day we'll see i kind of might have
something in the works
but i have this watch made by mason
marzilla
and i call it my timeless piece and
that's because
it's a watch you clip it on but ain't no
time no stress
no worry it's my timeless piece right
here so there's this one
watch made by cartier it's called like
the skeleton or something like that
and it's like 45 000
but i got a watch from the president of
my label
todd moskowitz and it was gold and i'm
not a gold guy so he said i could trade
it out for this watch so i might be
getting an iced
out cartier skeleton bones i don't know
what it's called i think it's a skeleton
watch because you could see through it
you can see the bones in it it's
beautiful so i think i'm gonna get that
this week
maybe raph simmons i tattooed your name
on my body
i love you to death if i were to marry a
man it would be rap simmons
here i have a spring summer o3
i collect all the archives this is just
a few of my favorites that i brought
because i have so many
but i like to go on grailed and uh
here's one of yeah this is spring summer
03 right here
i believe this one is o2 it doesn't say
it's a limited edition savage we got
the summer 05 texas pieces
i got the first shirt that you saw o3
consumed in a tank it fits like a glove
i look like i'm going to a rave when i
put this on
and then i have black palms rap simmons
limited edition from the 90s
i even have the coke can coca-cola made
like a
a collab with raph simmons there's a
black palms coke can i i should have
brought it
but um i love raff simmons i wear your
jeans every day
hit me up i'll walk your show anytime
i'm only 5
10 but i will walk
i mentioned a little earlier that i deal
with some
health issues chronic pancreatitis i
have to take this
zen pep it's an off brand it's a much
cheaper off brand of creon
it's a digestive enzyme that i have to
take before
any meal this in particular is 40 000
units yeah pancrealite paste is so
basically my live paste levels are
messed up and
i can't like digest food correctly and
it hurts really bad when i eat foods so
this is an essential for me big time
i've been dealing with pancreatitis for
four years now and counting
um it just became chronic over the last
like year or so so it's been a struggle
trying to like
make music and like catch all of all the
vibes
i live a very joyous happy life so all i
have to do is show up and bring
my smile
i brought one of my friends albums uh
chris
he sings for a band called saves the day
stay what you are i grew up on this
album
at your funeral is the first song and
it's just insane
almost every song i could recite every
lyric
down to firefly so i just thought i
would bring this i listened to a lot of
like
pop punk alternative emo music and
it started with albums like these i
talked to chris all the time
chris connolly was the singer of save
the day is uh one
i sent the album everything means
nothing to like three different artists
that i respect stephen jenkins from
third eye blind being one of them
mike posner of course my brother and i
think i sent it to chris connolly
and he was just like he gassed me up so
much he was just like this album is
perfect from
from start to finish all this stuff so
he made me feel really good
it's just surreal because i grew up on
this
so
oh black bear in his hats you hardly see
this guy without a hat
i mean right now i have the crew cut i
have the shaved head
this hat in particular is just some boys
from california from the valley they
make these hats to say valley on them i
really like them
i also like wearing my own merch
everything means nothing trucker
von dutch gives me a lot of free hats
because they know i'm just like a hat
guy
so i have a bunch of hats and then you
know more of my merch i did this collab
with alex miller for those who sin
and uh it's called loverboy i have that
tattooed i think
here but then i have more secretive hats
that i wear around the house you know
like playing with my son
and we watch adventure time and i put
this on
and we have our cereal in the morning
and
i'm so embarrassed right now
[Music]
so i black bear the musician actually
play instruments
believe it or not i actually play guitar
and bass mainly a little bit of drums
but i suck
mod son is better at drums than me my
pink
[ __ ] guitar as it as youngblood would
say my pink
[ __ ] guitar i love this thing it's
probably not in tune
[Applause]
[Music]
so
my pink guitar i love this guitar um i
use it on my home recordings
it's a gibson it's probably
it's not like an old guitar or anything
i think they just made a pink edition
and i just bought it right away on
reverb reverb is an app
that you can buy weird instruments
and old vintage stuff and i'm a geek so
i love it
i first started playing guitar when i
was six years old
i really wasn't good at first and
especially learning from pop punk
i only learned like power chords two
strings at a time
so i didn't really like get too good at
guitar until i started exploring blues
chords
and really just performing more but i
basically still suck i got like
i got like as i was like really good in
middle school
and everybody was like he's a prodigy
he's so good but i never like got better
than that
so like as good as i as i am a guitar i
was that good
at 13 and i just like didn't get any
better for some reason so if there's any
good instructors out there hit me up i
want to learn more
i suck
my last essential item is dealing with
mental health
um i'm a psychopath 911
i'm psycho so i use this app
headspace every day to
transform my anger manage my anxiety
there's even things for chronic pain
there's even things if you're like
trying to quit sugar there's like
meditations to help you with urges and
stuff like that so headspace
shout out also therapy
um i have a life coach i'm not afraid to
say that i talk to them
almost every single day um we do like
two minute blowouts where i'll just call
and i'll just blow out everything that's
going on
and usually i'm like you're not gonna
believe this ceno his name cena
i'm like you're not gonna believe this
all this this this is happening and i
have to do gq tomorrow and then i have
to shoot a music video
and then somehow i have to come up with
another hit this week and
and there's just so much going on and
once i finally talk to him it's like
my problems are like a plus problems and
i'm really just being a whiny little um
so i thought i would give ceno a call
we'll see if he answers
i think taking care of mental health and
if you if you deal with depression
and you deal with anxiety like i do and
you feel like you're just crawling out
of your skin and you can't sleep
talk to somebody i really uh
i really insist on doing that even if
it's just a friend
or go through insurance fine to find a
therapist
my therapist is a life coach his name's
sino
let's try and call him he picked up
look at this beautiful man oh look at
that set that up get that light going on
over here
what do we do every day sino
we have no shame in our game no blame on
our game we get grateful
we're all about the service we're all
about how can i make your life better
cameraman
that's what we do we drop lights all day
long with that big beautiful
and bear smile i love you
did you guys hear that what a wonderful
guy thank you cena
love you brother thank you love you man
bye you're my essential man
yeah all right
thank you guys for checking out my
essentials even if they were kind of
weird and not
physical materials i love you gq i'll
always do anything for you
if you want me to do any like topless
photos i'll do it
just hit me up you know my line 1 800
big black bear and uh
stay safe everybody wear a mask boat